.
♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ALL RIGHT, RIGHT OFF THE BAT, WE
GOT OLD MCBIDEN SAW A FARM.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
PUT YOUR MIND AT REST PEOPLE,
STOP WORRYING ABOUT STORING FOOD
AND ENERGY COSTS BECAUSE TODAY
JOE BIDEN'S ON THE CASE.
HE VISITED A FARM.
IT WAS PART LISTENING TOUR.
>> EVERY DAY THAT GETS PUSHED
BACK.
>> PUSHED BACK.
>> YES, APPEAR WE USUALLY RUN
OUT OF GROWING SEASON.
SO WE CAN'T CONTROL THAT.
WE CAN TYPICALLY PRODUCE ABOUT
60% OF THE DOUBLE CROP, BUT THE
OTHER STILL ALWAYS RISK INVOLVED
THAT I'M BY MYSELF.
COUPLE THINGS I WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT HERE.
WHAT WE HAD JUST WALKED THROUGH
BACK THERE.
>> YEP?
>> Laura: YEP.
PART MEANINGLESS SMALL TALK.
>> THERE YOU GO.
PLEASE, SIT DOWN.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO PUT
TO REST, EVERYBODY LOOKS AT ME
AND SAYS, HAVE YOU EVER BEEN ON
A FARM?
AND I REMIND THEM WHAT NOBODY
KNOWS.
I COME FROM THE STATE OF
DELAWARE, SINGLE LARGEST
INDUSTRY IN DELAWARE AND THE
DELMARVA OF DELAWARE VIRGINIA
PENINSULA THAT GOES DOWN IS
AGRICULTURE.
>> Laura: THANK YOU RAND
MCNALLY.
AND MORE TALK OF SPENDING MONEY
THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
>> EARLIER THIS YEAR THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
ANNOUNCED IT WOULD INVEST
$250 MILLION TO BOOST VERITY
FERTILIZER PRODUCTION.
AND I TURNED TO TOM AND SAID
DOUBLE THAT AND MAKE IT 500
MILLION.
IT'S SO DESPERATELY NEEDED.
>> Laura: WHY STOP THERE?
WHAT'S DESPERATELY NEEDED THOUGH
IS A PRESIDENT WHO DOESN'T OFFER
FAKE EMPATHY WHEN WHAT WE NEED
ARE REAL SOLUTIONS.
BUT FAKE EMPATHY IS ALL HE CAN
OFFER AND IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE
GOT WHEN HE WENT ON TO CHICAGO.
>> I COME FROM A FAMILY, AND
LIKE MOST OF YOU, THE PRICE OF
GAS WENT UP SIGNIFICANTLY, PRICE
OF FOOD WENT UP THAT'S WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT AT THE DINNER
TABLE, KITCHEN TABLE.
I COULDN'T AFFORD CHILD CARE.
NOT A JOKE.
I WAS MAKING $42,000 A YEAR,
WHICH WAS A LOT OF MONEY, AS A
U.S. SENATOR.
I COULDN'T AFFORD IT.
THANK GOD I GOT A BIG FAMILY.
MY DAD WOULD SAY FAMILY'S THE
BEGINNING, MIDDLE AND THE END.
>> Laura: THEN BIDEN TRIED TO
MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE
DISASTROUS STATE OF OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR LOWER STANDARD OF LIVING
BY COMPARING LIFE AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC TO THE DAYS OF
BIDEN INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> WE GAVE THEM A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY.
WE ADDED BACK 460,000 JOBS,
CRITICAL STATE AND LOCAL
WORKERS, EDUCATORS, FIRE
FIGHTERS, POLICE OFFICERS.
REMEMBER THOSE LONG LINES YOU'D
SEE ON THE TELEVISION?
PEOPLE LINING UP IN ALL KINDS OF
VEHICLES JUST TO GET A BOX OF
FOOD!
HOW QUICKLY WE FORGET!
AND WHAT DID THE MAGA CROWD WANT
TO DO?
FORGET IT.
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TO WAIT IN
LINE AN HOUR, HOUR AND A HALF TO
GET A BOX OF FOOD!
IN THEIR TRUNK.
JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Laura: DO HIS SPEECH WRITERS
NOT SEE THE IRONY HERE?
A FEW HOURS EARLIER HE GAVE A
SPEECH ABOUT INFLATION AND
RISING PRICES OF FOOD AND GAS UP
MORE THAN 43% UP NOW.
COSTS THAT ARE DUE TO HIS
POLICIES.
BUT PERHAPS THE WHITE HOUSE
MISSED THE HEADLINE ABOUT HOW
INFLATION IS SO BAD THAT SOME
WOMEN SAY THEY'RE SKIPPING MEALS
NOW IN ORDER TO MEET THEIR
FAMILY'S FOOD BUDGET.
BUT NONE OF WHAT BIDEN IS DOING
IS GOING TO MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE.
HIS MOVES TO RELEASE THE 30
BILLION BARRELS FROM OUR
STRATEGIC RESERVES WAS WORSE
THAN A FLOP IT'S NOW
COMPROMISING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY BY FLEETING OUR ENERGY
SOURCE THAT WAS BEING SAVED FOR
EMERGENCIES.
MEANWHILE, IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH,
THE WHITE HOUSE IS PLANNING TO
FURTHER ERODE OUR ECONOMIC
POSITION, VIS-A-VIS CHINA.
THE GOINGISTS INSIDE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARE ON THE VERGE
OF CONVINCING SCRANTON JOE TO
HELP THE CCP BY DROPPING TRUMP'S
TARIFF.
AND APPARENTLY FOR THAT GREAT
DEAL, AMERICA WILL GET NOTHING.
NOW, REMEMBER, CHINA IS SO
SLEAZY AND SO DISHONEST IT
HASN'T EVEN LIVED UP TO ITS
PHASE ONE AGREEMENT TO BUY
$200 BILLION WORTH OF
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS FROM US.
IT OBVIOUSLY KNEW WITH TRUMP OUT
WHEN THEY AGREED TO IT THEY
COULD WELCH ON THE BARGAIN AND
THERE WOULD BE NO CONSEQUENCES
UNDER BIDEN.
SO HOW BAD WOULD THIS BE?
ALREADY WITH TRUMP'S TARIFFS IN
PLACE CHINA IS ON PACE TO ENJOY
A TRADE SURPLUS OF OVER
$400 BILLION WITH THE U.S. THIS
YEAR ALONE.
SO THE WAY THINGS LOOK, BIDEN IS
SIMPLY GOING TO DECLARE THE
WHOLE TARIFF THINGS WAS A
MISTAKE THAT CONTRIBUTED TO
HIGHER PRICES TO ALL CONSUMERS.
SOMEHOW THOUGH BIDEN THINKS HE
CAN MOLIFY WITH COMMENTS ABOUT
CHINA WITH COMMENTS DISGUISED AS
TOUGH TALK.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT AMERICA AS A
DIMINISHING POWER AND I SAID MR.
PRESIDENT IT'S NEVER BEEN A GOOD
BET TO BET AGAINST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
NO ONE'S EVER WON BETTING
AGAINST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: HE WAS TALKING TO
PRESIDENT XI THERE.
BUT THE TRUTH IS AMERICA MEANS
TO BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
DECOUPLING THAT MURDEROUS BUNCH
CALLED CHINA.
IT'S TIME WE PULLED BACK FROM
OUR ESSENTIAL MANUFACTURING
BECAUSE THE TRUE COST OF OUR
DEPENDENCE ON THIS REPRESS I
HAVE REGIME IS ALREADY BEING
FELT IN BABY FORMULA SHORTAGES,
DRUG SHORTAGES AND NOW SHORTAGES
IN IV CONTRAST FLUID IN
HOSPITALS.
JOHNS HOPKINS SENT A LETTER TO
ALL OF ITS STAFF THAT THE CAUSE
OF THIS SHORTAGE IS THE COVID
PANDEMIC.
BUT OF COURSE THE REAL CAUSE IS
THE SHANGHAI LOCK DOWN.
TURNS OUT SHANGHAI IS WHERE MUCH
OF THE IV FLUID IS PRODUCED.
THIS IS TERRIFYING.
IT HAS TO CHANGE.
WE CAN'T BE HELD HOSTAGE BY
CHINA OR THE ONE WORLDERS HERE
IN THE US WHO SOLD US OUT FOR SO
LONG.
SO TODAY'S TRIP TO THE FARM WAS
JUST ANOTHER DESPERATE ACT.
AN ACT THAT WAS POORLY
CHOREOGRAPHED BY THE WHITE HOUSE
COMS TEAM.
THEY REALLY THINK THIS IS THE
ALL A MESSAGING PROBABLE DON'T
THEY?
THAT AMERICANS ARE STUPID.
SO STUPID TO BELIEVE ANY OF
BIDEN'S GESTURES WILL ALTER THE
ECONOMIC PLIGHT THEY SEE BEFORE
THEM.
BUT THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY ARE SMARTER THAN THE
ELITES THINK AND IF THEY COULD
RIGHT NOW YEAH THEY'D SEND BIDEN
AND ALL HIS ENABLERS BACK TO THE
FA